[Music]
in weed breath news we breath submit my
whoa dude whoa whoa a new marijuana
breathalyzer board that will detect high
drivers with fair methods oh [ __ ] not
even I can do that I didn't know either
you can drive wall huh okay kids mm-hmm
I don't think so
but what if the weed is ingested like
you from a brownie or something you can
still breathalyzer
maybe that's hard to tell that's a good
option that's probably really with us in
bland sir
and there's different ways of smoking
till you could faint you could vape it
you can [ __ ] bong it you can [ __ ] it
oh and sometimes you could get like
orange juice and you put that [ __ ] with
ice cubes in the bong not that I do that
anymore but that's just bomb protons mom
yeah and then they have bomb juice now
so it makes a different flavors and [ __ ]
like hookah we did you say orange ice
cubes yep take one soda and make orange
juice orange juice and I just throw ice
cubes in there it chills it orange soda
ice cubes might be a billion-dollar idea
it doesn't work so does when you try to
free sodas it doesn't work because it's
very effervescent so it's just like
sugar and then this way because how the
hell do they do the Coca Cola Slurpee
David well that's different though
because there's no bubbles in the
Slurpee so just you're talking about the
orange sort of flavor in ice okay I
thought about putting ourselves into an
ice cube cuz I try to fight you dude I
was just gonna say dude I try that as a
kid I try to freeze soda into ice cubes
it just separates so the sugar goes to
the bottom
it separates on top it's just water and
that's really cold so you couldn't make
a cactus cooler popsicle could not do it
you guys used to make the ghetto
coca-cola popsicles where you getting a
latex glove and you pour coke into it
and then you put a chopstick in you tie
it and then you freeze it in then when
you're done it's a big hand
it tastes like latex latex nobody ever
did that did that and now
we me and my friends all my my
refridgerator have like five hands in it
that's one of those things that all kids
did but like you and your friends going
to be just to put this in perspective
you know when you are a kid and you may
have latex gloves at that time it still
had a latex powder in it yeah yeah
did you watch this residue but yeah cuz
now they don't because the people had an
allergic reaction to it but at that time
they had latex maybe I was too excited
that I just overlooked it God he did not
rinse it off whatsoever he's like wait
you guys never see no that's like no
because we would have been like I don't
want to see he's like [ __ ] a textbook
right that's why that was the first
question I had you want to saw me with
the hand coke oh you miss no I would've
looked at all off already you would have
been so [ __ ] jealous
it sounds cool in theory but I also
something about eating a hand I don't
need it no it's a big balloon hand it
doesn't look like this oh can you pour
the coconut stretches out so it turns
it's like all bubbly oh that's kind of
cool yeah yeah but nobody did that when
I think of hands I think of unsanitary
things huh you don't saying when you see
a hand yeah yeah I just think of it
gross but not when it looks like a coke
crystal burger a helper glove oh that
just is delicious wait wait I'm crystal
from the ground turkey ground beef
ground whatever I just [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] mm-hmm Hamburger Helper all right
so this story it's about this weed
breathalyzer thing oh [ __ ] me sorry
contagious me so this company is called
Hamlet hound labs and they created this
breath marijuana breathalyzer that
they're saying is 1 billion times more
sensitive than alcohol breathalyzers
that it can detect
THC in people's breath if they've smoked
within like two or three hours which is
the same amount of time that that's when
right after you've ingested marijuana
then that's when you're the most
impaired and you shouldn't be driving a
2 to 3 hours dude when I would smoke I
knew that I was coming down after two to
three hours I'm like oh I'm regular now
that was like that what time [ __ ] yeah
so then like before that that's when
it's you're the most impatient yeah yeah
oh my bad I understood it as it can
detect it after the t3 our one no that's
why it's fair methods because there's a
lot of people that now it's legal in
nine states and there's a lot of people
that recreationally use it and
responsibly use it but if they're
smoking and they're right after they're
driving and they get caught then that's
obviously not being responsible and
that's when they would get prosecuted we
saw some people smoke like a joint right
in front of a restaurant like in Little
Tokyo and I was just thinking like man
this would have never flew can you do it
and you can't know they were just
smoking on a bench in front of the
restaurant like oh it wasn't right on
them but it was just within the plaza
I thought you still have to smoke in the
privacy of your home in your home I
don't know what the law is but there are
a lot of people getting stoned in public
and not no one's really bad in the night
I don't think treating it like
cigarettes and alcohol like tobacco any
yeah cuz you can't drink in public
either like that yeah you can't have an
open bottle of liquor and that [ __ ] is
weak is [ __ ] dude why thank you I want
to be able to walk around with a [ __ ]
drink like Vegas that's why you like
Vegas I love Vegas I get a [ __ ] yard
sticker that whatever the [ __ ] it is
he's like lemonade I like Vegas I don't
even drink by I'll enjoy watching other
people drink in public it's Vaughn dude
yeah they just seem like they're having
such a good time like we are and they
don't have to be like cooped up
somewhere it's just two people like
drinking away and I'm like those two
grandmas that way that I'm awesome
it makes me happy I always think a drunk
party girls and wearing heels that are
way too
jewelry buzzes heels yeah I think the
baby dress I love that [ __ ]
so true my favorite place to get drunk
is weddings oh yeah by far I think
weddings are deep we're gonna get [ __ ]
up at Jimmy's wedding oh for sure
I wish drunk too dude I'm gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] crawl in the car with you
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be open
bar gonna [ __ ] hotel over there oh
yeah that's all that I can't wait the
last two wait never get scared of
consequences when you drink and you
[ __ ] puke and you feel nasty oh yeah
I will never do that again
that's like me every time that's why I
don't drink it oh there's like this
weird sense of like camaraderie that
happens when you drink with people
mm-hmm you know I meet like your your
friendship continually levels up I know
it's me because what I drink I feel it
with you guys too yeah and then at 10
p.m. when I'm gonna fall asleep I flick
but it feels it goes away I know I was
so proud of you into almost like 9:15
yeah the next party and I'm like yeah I
know you didn't make it to the strip
club is mine I keep forgetting like him
with him anymore that was not be time
next time you have been sleeping at this
strip club that wouldn't wake them up
sleep at clubs cuz I would just pass
them I would just be against the speaker
I'll just be passed down my fine you
guys want to go right now back that
would be funny if we just bought all
these laughs that's as good as sleepy as
dude and then like that's a video that's
a really good one Vegas [ __ ] drinks
are hella potent too and I didn't think
about that [ __ ] because they're even the
bloody marys get me like a little
smashed and they're a little bigger than
they're normally supposed to be
apparently they're good ticket they're
trying to limit free drinks now and I'm
like you guys go your business yeah
that's the whole reason why people
dumping money into the tables the first
place how many vodka redbulls you see me
or will the plain crabs it's like insane
at least 45 and now I gotta pay for
those [ __ ] that never 99 gamble do you
know exactly
not now I feel less brave yeah now I'm
probably gonna start taking chips off
the table you don't want that
you'll want that Vegas you don't want
now what that Vegas it wasn't to be
responsible yes
that's stupid they should start passing
out a pills yeah I'll be massaging and
gammas give life savings I only like the
way Vegas looks when it's dark and
there's lights everywhere oh yeah in the
morning time when we go to bed make a
busted curl at the club the club during
the day those girls who had like the
[ __ ] mom painted on titties and
they're just like sweating and they're
greasy I'm like I have never been so
uninterested in a pair of tits in my
life like it's just you look gross true
crazy I saw so many tits will mirror at
the strip club that I was like dude I
think I'm good on tits for like a long
time manatee you saw so much kits that
day then after a while it's like you
know the magic is gone I had sex with
Nicki that night I literally did she's
like hey relax there you got the hotel
brochures and just cover them up that's
it just you know what I like to do in a
day time is I like to do the senior
citizen stuff like the tourist stuff I
like sightseeing and then I like to do
the pool that's the fight like you gotta
do the poison Sox no because we're we
run date deep we have a big crew and
then when we're at the pool it's so
packed you'll never get to sit together
we're not going out there at a
responsible time we got to go on Monday
Wednesday I know going during the week
that's Vega supposed to be are the most
disgusting thing that I've ever seen in
my life
it really it just looks like salt and
semen in there so good for the skin God
dude room cuz it's just packed
elbow-to-elbow I mean just don't drink
it in you're fine dude the real [ __ ]
though David as you go on that London
Eye thing and you pay for the drinking
one and it's like unlimited drinks what
like for one whole rotation because
that's the that's the amount of time it
takes and that's the [ __ ] value dude
you believe that thing stumble in around
like
the [ __ ] wheelchair please like that
should the dopest I basically told the
bartender like give me two of everything
like every time I went up to him because
there's a bartender in there with you as
you go around Vegas I don't know what
changed in my soul but I don't like to
be intoxicated in public anymore we're
back in a day it was like let me get
[ __ ] up and lose control and not know
what the [ __ ] happened whether it's
drugs or alcohol or whatever mmm but now
I'm just like [ __ ] man I still wanted
that muscle I gonna steal steal from me
or try to [ __ ] grab my butt I don't
know oh yeah but I'm just saying like
there's just you I don't know like you
know thinking yeah I'm just like [ __ ]
there's so many dangers in the world I
don't know you guys don't do that III
know it's hung up I I just I also do
like how when you drink you're able to
let go a little bit and I wish drunk
driving wasn't illegal that's not what I
mean unfortunate I wish there was a like
drunk driving bumper cars maybe not
drunk then maybe like slightly
inebriated what if everyone in this
writing is drunk driving Gio that's why
we were going gold card I understand his
logic so that these people don't
everyone agrees to inhale and there's no
innocent bystanders of course I don't
want of those unfortunate events I'm
talking about imagine you go to this
arena where you get to drunk drink and
drive and everyone signed up for the
same things called go-karts my friend
and that's well we have or just go-karts
cuz think about it we went we had some
drinks and then we did go Chris
when we bump each other we get in
trouble we're not to bump each other I
know you should be able to go kart and
draw and and drink yeah like you should
know to have a drink in your go-karts to
have a [ __ ] cup holder for your drink
and they should have a lid on and you
have a breathalyzer and if you're not
charged you can't even drive it that'd
be sick as [ __ ] that's the business you
IKEA should have you know how they have
those long carts where people push you
they should have a front area for adults
where you could have a [ __ ] beer
cubby and then somebody
push through all of IKEA all that be
tired long carts that people put when
you put all the stuff in the firetruck
ones where the kids going it just was
like a long dolly or whatever I think I
have a bit in a long time
I think yours are the Home Depot ones
when it's blue right and then what are
you talking about
I'm Bob oh oh well you put the big
furniture in and have you ever just like
all the Home Depot things you yeah
either one like IKEA where you have to
pull it out from the machine yeah okay
yeah that's the [ __ ] cuz I think those
[ __ ] back yeah I do
cuz Vanessa was pushing me on it
yesterday and all I thought was I wish
there was a fun seat with a [ __ ] beer
copy of front dighby time do they serve
beer
[Music]
[Music]